now at our peaceful foxnews.com a former
FBI agent is coming forward to explain
why she left the bureau and is sounding
the alarm over How Deeply polarized
things have become within the FBI and
that law enforcement agency it should be
the world's Premier law enforcement
agency it no longer is now Nicole Parker
she left the bureau after nearly 13
years now she worked on high profile
cases like the Parkland school shooting
the 2017 Fort Lauderdale Airport
shooting the Caesar psyock Pike bomb
case the multi-million dollar Ponzi
schemes and and so much more but she
left and now says the bureau has lost
the truth and the trust of the American
people this is what she writes over the
course of my 12 plus years of service
the FBI's trajectory transformed on
paper the bureau's mission remained the
same but its priorities and governing
principles they shifted dramatically the
FBI became politically weaponized
starting from the top in Washington
trickling down to field offices Parker
also says that there has been a shift in
recruiting practices and a quote
lowering of eligibility requirements
which is negatively impacting the
agency's performance in closing she
writes for me distancing myself from
egregious mistakes immoral behavior and
politically charged actions taken by a
small but destructive few FBI employees
became exhausting here to explain a lot
more former FBI special agent Nicole
Parker we welcome her
wow
thank you for coming thank you for
having me
I think you were working for Merrill
Lynch yes uh you're on the top floor yes
of the World Trade Center on 911 Central
Center what I was on the top floor of
the world financial center on 2001.
correct on September 11th 2001 I was
working for Merrill Lynch I was on the
top floor of the World Financial Center
wow I heard the first plane crashed into
the North Tower I did not see it but I
was at my desk I ran to the window me
myself and my colleagues witnessed the
second plane crashing into the second
tower Tower two
um that's a day that changed my life so
you apply you have this great career
trajectory in finance you decide you
know what I want to apply for the FBI uh
your in your year there were 45 000
applicants you will want them 900 chosen
so that was a great honor then you went
to Quantico and you went through what
six months of training correct yeah okay
what was the FBI like then and what
happened so you know I came to the FBI
because I love America I wanted to serve
this country and I knew on 9 11 that I
wanted to give back one day I came in
and it was an amazing experience to join
the FBI I worked with the finest and the
brightest in the FBI local law
enforcement our federal prosecutors
these are outstanding and wonderful
people and we were really just getting
in there and fighting crime and putting
bad people behind bars and that's why I
came and I noticed through the course of
my my career
the trajectory of the FBI seemed to have
changed and it seemed to have been more
you know in the last couple years more
than ever and it was just something that
I started to wonder is this the FBI that
I signed on to
but the the amazing Heroes of the FBI
they're still there they're still doing
the hard work and unfortunately it seems
that some of that hard work is getting
drowned out by some of the negativity
that's happening I couldn't believe in
2016
um the FBI actually sent in early
October after they were warned in August
by Bruce Horton not to trust the dirty
Russian dossier of Hillary Clinton so
they send in early October 2016 agents
to interview Christopher Steele the
author offer him a million dollars to
corroborate it he can't corroborate it
he doesn't get the million dollars but
then they used it as the bulk of
information
to literally spy on Carter page and
backdoor spy on President Trump then
candidate Trump
and the amazing thing is it was
unverifiable but they they went to a
fisa court it says at the top verified
they couldn't verify it at that moment
I was like what are they they put their
fingers on the scale of that election
they had the Hunter's laptop in 2019 and
yet they were talking to the FBI weekly
was talking to all big tech companies be
careful there might be misinformation
campaigns from other countries did you
see that type of politics look the
bottom line is is that the agents in the
field that are working the the crimes
the violent crimes you know the crimes
against children the human trafficking
you know we're trying to protect
Americans frankly I was never asked to
participate in anything that was
political but I knew that it was
happening around me because you know
Americans knew and unfortunately that
negatively impacts the mission of the
bureau because we need the buy-in of the
American people to support us when we're
doing our job and so you know 99 of the
FBI employees are working hard we're
doing real work you know I I would I
really feel like it's important for
America to understand that there are
people out there and they are
sacrificing my dearest friend special
agent Laura schwarzenberger and and
another agent as well as multiple three
other agents that were shot does anyone
know that does anyone know about Laura
schwarzenberger and the other most
people can't mention a single person
shot the media only focuses on cases
that they can politicize well and I
think it's important for us to know that
when there are people at the top that
are politicizing the FBI
so we know because of Charles Grassley
and Senator Ron Johnson and Congressman
Jim Jordan that all of these
whistleblowers now have come forward we
don't know who they are yet you're the
first public one and that there will be
many more I'm told perhaps dozens
and this article comes out what has been
the feedback
some positive I mean especially from the
FBI
you know there are a lot of amaze
ments and the males that are doing a may
work at the FBI people I work shoulder
to shoulder with not just in the Miami
division but across the entire country
and America needs to know that there are
incredible people of the highest level
of Integrity that are holding the line
those individuals are not at the luxury
to speak up and voice their concerns
because you know sometimes when you
speak up it puts a Target on your back
and so there might be times when you're
not actually involved with something
that's happening but it doesn't mean
that you don't agree with what's
happening but in essence to you know you
just keep your head low do your work
stay off the radar and try to do the
right thing oh you're eight years away
from a pension you gave up a lot
you know for me
I'm a woman of faith and I believe in
God
and I know that God and I know that God
is watching over me and the amazing
people in the FBI
this was really hard for you
it was a very difficult decision I love
this I mean I sacrificed a lot working
for the FBI what I want Americans to
understand
when you're going to an active shooter
site and you're seeing young children it
takes the toll on you I mean we are
seeing things my phone was ringing 24 7
365. I was the crimes on the high seas
coordinator for the FBI the types of
things that we're exposed to it's very
dark and it's a sacrifice to serve this
country but we do it because we love
America you are very courageous we wish
you godspeed in all your future
endeavors thank you for your courage to
write this and speak out and I know it
was hard to do thank you we appreciate
it
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else